you know what's sinful to TV and we
think it's finally time to do something
about it that's why we're excited to
announce the launch of our new channel
DB sins with the link in the description
to head over and see our first episode
on Game of Thrones
as for this video you may have noticed
some of our videos have gone missing and
we want to make sure we're getting them
back out for your sin loving us we
normally go down to one video a week in
September this month we're going to use
the extra space to re-uploads on the
lost episodes back to the channel and
we'll be doing the same on Saturdays as
well after this month will continue to
reload videos on Saturdays until they're
all back up on the gym all right that's
enough announcement for one day
evil guys hood ornament close-up cliche
show bad guys feet walking first before
revealing actual bad guy cliche dead old
Knights coffin cliche they wrote this
movie with a film cliches book open on
the table didn't they
some little grandchildren perhaps I have
no need for them to die there is no way
the guys in that tank heard this comment
so I have to assume it's just a huge
coincidence at the cannons turn just
after the bad guy mentions maybe killing
civilians did I see God did enough
wisdom faint Schmidt looks at the wall
decoration and says yep there's probably
a secret snake I can push somewhere that
will give me the tesseract also that's
how you hide something you really want
to hide behind a gargantuan wood carving
wall display of a famous tree that
symbolizes the guardian of wisdom and
fate
yep the entire movie is a tesseract
setup and since the tesseract is
ultimately only a MacGuffin and the
Avengers anyway that makes this all the
more stupid fun house mirror Chris Evans
you probably shouldn't cinemasins a war
newsreel at least not in the theater you
can either skip north fast-forward film
asshole want to shut up so none of these
other people who were non assholes and
who were crying at the war newsreels
stood up with the skinny guy against
ignorant about projection guy what a
bunch of dicks irony hey does he have a
homing device on Steve pick on someone
your own size cliche anyone out there
see this football game between the
Brooklyn Dodgers and the Patterson
Panthers in May of 1942 yes because this
game was never scheduled and never
happened you fucking liar sergeant James
Barnes shipping out Franklin the first
thing Laura character fully states his
own name to someone he already knows
because even the screenwriters couldn't
figure out how to introduce this guy
after he appeared out of nowhere to save
Steve
Jesus movie is basically setting up
everything in the Marvel Universe except
Captain America collects crap yes
important scientists just happens to
overhear an argument detailing the
perfectness of Steve for the secret
science project with the arrival of Toby
Jones we now have way too many people in
this movie who will be announcers in the
Hunger Games with all this opening the
box exposing the tesseract and
conducting all this energy with it
shouldn't open Thor and Loki be alerted
about it right now
instead of like 70 years from now I
guess in this military rules an order
aren't important they play by modern-day
reality-show rules stupidest criteria
ever you want to pick the guy who would
get himself killed at the first enemy
grenade every single other candidate did
what a good soldier and person with
common sense does they ran only Steve
Rogers was stupid enough to jump on a
grenade that at the time he jumped
wasn't even gonna hurt anyone because
everyone else had run away is this a
test he's still skinny yeah well what
does it matter if he's skinny especially
if you're gonna inject him with almost
super steroids later anyway I sure am
glad I brought it so that I could segue
into a history lesson about Nazi Germany
cesium amplifies everything that is
inside so good becomes great bit becomes
less scientific serum makes judgment
calls about what is good and bad and
then amplifies them against this power
we now possess world-changing power from
Odin's treasure chest can be defensed by
performance-enhancing drugs on earth it
can't be 1940s Brooklyn unless there are
youths playing stickball in the street
somebody get that kid his sandwich well
somebody needs a sandwich the only way
we'll know if this is truly a lot of
power is if all the machines start
sparking at once like most things in
comic book universes that make a person
bigger the pants stay on and in this
case there's still a perfect fit let's
not start sucking each other's just yet
how do you know what this very moment it
didn't give him brain damage or
something why would this process leave
one vial of serum behind after the
experiment and how did this spy guy no
one would be left in fact why blow up
the observation room when everyone was
busy shaking hands over the successful
procedure dude could have tried to take
it when no one was looking then blow up
the observation room of someone yelled
at him we interrupt this superhero movie
to bring you the untouchables why does
the spider I've directly towards agent
Carter after she shot the driver from
behind from a much longer distance there
are plenty of roads he could turn down
to avoid this and get to where he needs
to go
also why can agent Carter hit a driver
from behind in a much longer distance
but not hit this dude's head from a much
shorter distance good thing there's only
one yellow taxi in New York City at the
time Steve is trying to catch up to a
yellow taxi the guy with gun doesn't
immediately shoot super-soldier that
lands on his car roof and when he does
finally use his gun of course the hero
somehow magically dodges all the bullets
he can't see coming
man what a nasty wreck that guy must
look like a mangled horror show right
holy shit that wreck was meaningless to
cheesy moments with fake shields by the
41 minute mark
Gyo movie also taxi company name
suddenly apropos when he was driving the
cab he was basically trying to avoid
Steve the whole time going about it in a
random manner taking wild turns to avoid
him and even trying to throw him off the
car but this is where he wanted to go
home and if so why was the original car
going in a completely different
direction before agent Carter shot the
driver so the plan was to go into the
military compound to blow up the
observation room expect the explosion to
be a diversion for everyone steal one
vial of serum that just happened to be
there kill the scientist hope the
formula hasn't been shared with anyone
else
escape up some stairs avoid or kill all
military police run out the front door
take a car which has two henchmen and it
just in case you're followed drive to
the pier where you expect that no one
would follow you anymore and you just be
able to board this submersible with
absolutely no witnesses or other issues
hi Joe science division did she know
they were talking about Hydra all the
way over here and remember when Phillips
brings up Hydra they talk for a little
bit
I dream so agent Carter had to be waved
further back when he said that is my
norm you know I got was you you okay so
if you used Steve he wouldn't have to
fight alone what he couldn't he just be
a regular soldier who kicks a lot more
ass than usual sergeant James Barnes in
107 I've signed more of these condolence
letters today and then I would care to
count
but the name does sound familiar I'm
sorry Steve just accepts that James is
dead because Philip says the name sounds
familiar but the name is King James
Barnes it's not Lyle Alzado or some did
Colonel Phillips not hear about the
story where Steve track down that spider
iving a car while on foot and jumped
into the water to stop that guy in his
high-tech submersible what these
anti-aircraft guns have only one plane
to shoot at but they miss like
stormtroopers driver of this truck
doesn't hear the easily jirobo commotion
this cat beats up the bad guys every one
of these trucks has a crew of dudes
coming over to check it except this one
where one lone soldier comes to check so
that cap can knock him out with a shield
also no one hears the loud Clank of the
shield or sees a guy flying 10 feet
backwards or sees cap with his
practically glow in the dark shield
running away King seriously not one
lookout in this entire Hydra base not on
guard at the sensitive tesseract weapons
depot zoom an enhanced technology in the
1940s
[Music]
I'm Captain America I'm a super soldier
who just saw an important scientist
running away from me and oh wait what's
this my best friend in the entire world
so wait did everyone who was fighting
down here evacuate before the ground
floor could self-destruct my evil boss
is equally matched with the hero and
they've only thrown one punch each
better separate them we're only an hour
into the movie so sure let's try and
fool the audience into thinking the main
character died sounds plausible
right wait
they didn't make him a real captain did
they that was just his costume stage
name for the USO shows and right
the only real soldiering he's done has
been since he went AWOL off the base
here to rescue his buddy and no one
could have promoted him to captain
because of that should it yet not one
Pio w died during that confusing battle
in the dark with the Hydra soldiers all
armed with the power of Odin are you
keeping the outfit right you know what
it's kind of growing on me
not me this is a waste of everyone's
time agent Carter's gonna see this of
course there will be a misunderstanding
it's dumb and just stop doing this bit
already also that was a terrible waste
of Natalie Dormer yes I think it was
cute movie moment but what the fuck
actually no that's not even a cute movie
moment this crazy chick is a danger to
others also it's now officially even
crazier that she couldn't kill the Hydra
spy earlier I guess none of these guys
with the Odin guns that disintegrate
people really want to use the movie
waste 79 minutes on backstory and only
to throw the first 20 true Captain
America action scenes into one
rapid-fire montage guys shooting Captain
America escapes an exploding building on
his motorcycle what the fuck is going on
randomness man they really let the
newsreel guys get up close to top-secret
information things excitement neither
can the assholes we receive these
weapons since when do these weapons need
time to build up energy when we first
saw them they could fire at will now it
has a delay every Hydra agent that we've
tried to take alive is all one of them
sure guys shoot at the shield and not
the bike that was your good von Wilhelm
who liked most was awful at being a
Hydra this car has a clear shot but
decides to suck at life instead sure
just run up real close to Captain
America instead of standing at a safe
distance and firing your disintegration
gun in what world does this make sense
yet another asshole be dreaming about
flowers or sunrises or some instead of
firing his gun when the power of Odin
doesn't work try flamethrowers they
wanted to kill him before but now
they've come to their senses and just
want to take him prisoner magic zip
lines shot from a unicorns dream Red
Skull and crew just stare at the
incoming Special Forces guys instead of
you know firing at them and stuff oh I
see took Americans to make these guns
work Amica ex machina hey nobody in a
hydra uniform better shoot that Captain
America guy in the side or the back
while he's freely traipsing through this
hangar okay magic traveling chain
attached to the ceiling of hangar by
leprechaun tears and dragon wishes I
guess even back in the 1940s they used
nas to make cars go faster
give me a break lady fate of the world
hello
because physics man that was one awesome
shot of paper football random bad guys
continue to be random with no variety to
the randomness even with the advantage
Red Skull aims for the fucking shield
jeez who wants the power of the gods
after the track record in this film even
after this it took 70 years for the gods
to notice so cap push Red Skull into the
Machine and broke it then skull picked
up the tesseract which either killed him
or transported him somewhere in space is
this a lucky victory for the Americans
here or what massive amounts of energy
conducted on the plane somehow doesn't
destroy it even though we saw one small
particle now Howard Stark on his ass
earlier why can't he just parachute at
the back of this plane or jump when it
gets close to the ground he's being
superhuman why is he just resigned to
death the game it's from May 1941 I know
cuz I was there oh come on he just
happened to be at that game and they
just decided to pick a game from 1941
even though they know he's Captain
America and his plane went down much
later than that and they had a take well
that's not anticlimactic or anything to
our advertisement for the Avengers ends
with literal advertisement for the
Avengers
they cut off one head two more shall
take its place hail Hydra
a few weeks back the folks at naturebox
tricked me into doing an ad for him by
sending a box of delicious snacks I
thought that would be the end of it and
for a while it was but then they sent me
another box now I didn't order this box
I definitely didn't pay for it
but here it was in front of me in the
flesh a new box full of even more
varieties of delicious healthy snacks I
thought about what to do the right thing
to do would probably be to send the box
back that's not happening I suppose I
could send them a check to pay for the
snacks that's not so I've decided the
best and safest course of action is to
just make another ad form hopefully this
way they'll feel compensated for the
value of the snacks and perhaps even
continue sending the free unsolicited
vittles now I cannot suggest that this
is the best course of action for you to
get some delicious naturebox snacks
you're probably better off going the
traditional route trying naturebox calm
and it's I mean you can always just
create an ADD form and sit there and
wait for them to start sending you
snacks and hell I don't know that may be
their plan but I doubt it looking to eat
healthier snacks trying to eat better
wake up every morning thinking of new
and creative ways to cram granola in
your mouth naturebox has your back and
just for our viewers they have a 50% off
special on your first order at HR box
comm slash cinemasins oh and they ship
for free
yeah we don't think it would be more
comfortable in the booth No
would it make you more comfortable I'd
like to share a revelation that I've had
during my time here it came to me when I
tried to classify her species ladies and
gentlemen welcome to my underground lair
I have gathered here before me the
world's deadliest assassins and yet each
of you has failed to kill Austin Powers
[Music]
and many of them are so nerd' so
hopelessly dependent on the system that
they will fight to protect it are you
listening to me neo but were you looking
at the woman in the red dress
[Music]
you remember the little red button yeah
push the little red button put on a seat
belt
[Applause]